Speaker 1: Right wingers are completely losing
their minds over this train derailment that took
place in Ohio. Now, one of the reasons I've not
said much about it yet is that it is still really
not clear what or who is to blame. And the right
is very quick to blame, woke and racism for the
event that took place, which is a really strange
thing to do and to blame. It's conceivable that
what we have here is a problem in terms of lack
of regulation. It it's really not clear yet.
The NTSB report so far says that the and the
the cause here was a malfunction with a wheel
bearing which overheated. And it's not yet clear
what caused the wheel bearing to overheat. Now,
of course, there are concerns about chemicals
in the area, both in the air and the impact on
water quality. Mike DeWine said he would be he
would stick with the bottled water for the time
being. Erin Brockovich is is expressing concern
about whether there are more harmful chemicals
than what is being revealed. We are still trying
to learn a lot about it, but many on the right
have figured out what this is all about. Here's
Greg GUTFELD. He believes Wokeism is to blame.
Speaker 2: Mayor Pete is busy. He's got
some pretty big issues that he's dealing
with. For example, do you see what he said about
construction workers, that it's really a problem,
that their skin color doesn't match the
diversity of a community that's really got
upset people? I remember as a kid walking around
and I was very upset whenever I saw of my like a
minority construction worker, I said, My God.
Speaker 1: Now understand that these are two
completely separate issues. And if indeed Mayor
Pete weighed in about diversity of construction
workers, it has nothing to do whatsoever with this
incident. But Fox News doesn't care about that.
Speaker 2: They all have to look like me. You
know, I had that was a secondary that was a
primary concern, that all the other things about
safety and whether the product was that was just
that was not as important. This is the problem
with catering to the woke. They don't have time
for real problems. So they chased these completely
made up once train derails or a plane crashes. But
they worry about the white construction worker
offending somebody who doesn't exist. I don't
believe a single person has ever expressed
a problem about a construction worker skin
color unless it was another skin. Get another
construction worker. But this is the if you
want to talk about a toxic spill, look at
well, look at Wokeism. And what what what
politics is doing to every part of life. I mean.
Speaker 1: Okay, so Greg GUTFELD says wokeism and
Pete booted judge being distracted by wokeism
is the problem. Charlie Kirk goes even further
and his do I even call it an analysis? Charlie
Kirk says the Ohio train derailment is part of
the war on white people. I remember. Oh, the left
is always victim. They're the victims. It is the
right that is now regularly saying Christians are
the victims and white people are the victims and
conservatives are the victims here. Here's
Charlie Kirk's analysis of the situation.
Speaker 2: Not a single member of the Biden
regime would dare to go. To this portion of
Ohio and breathe in the air because they know
it's dangerous. They know that it is actively
poisoning. The citizens. Of Eastern Ohio. So why
is it that they kind of shrug their shoulders?
And they say, Ah, yeah, okay, whatever. It's
very simple. It's because the war on white
people continues, right? Why would you care for
the white working class voters in eastern Ohio?
You haven't cared about them in other reasons
or other portions, and I will prove it to you.
If this train derailment happened in
downtown Atlanta in the densely populated
black neighborhoods. This would be the number one
news story. It would be Flint water crisis 2.0.
Speaker 1: Oh, well, that's interesting. We know
how sincere Charlie Kirk is in saying he would
be just as concerned, obviously, if the train
derailment disproportionately affected black
people because of the years that Charlie Kirk has
spent talking about the Flint water crisis. Oh,
wait. He hasn't spent years talking about the
Flint water crisis. And so this is yet again,
we are the victims. It is racist or it's a reverse
racism, which is a delightful term that they like
to talk about. But what they won't discuss is
whether the train derailment might be the result
of corporate greed and deregulation. Now, I'm
not ready to say it is. Understand? I want to
follow the facts. And based on the NTSB report so
far, it isn't clear to me that the issue here is
one of corporate greed and deregulation. But if
we're speculating about what this is and we're
going to speculate, well, it's because of Wolk or
it's because of anti-white racism or whatever the
case may be. If we're speculating, let's include
more reasonable speculation as well. Then we go to
Marjorie Taylor. GREENE Marjorie Taylor GREENE
says the issue here is pit bull judge. That's
really the problem. That's the cause.
Speaker 3: But the real problem, Sean,
is Pete better judge. He's the
secretary of transportation,
and he's more interested in equity and inclusion
in his hiring practices and grant giving schemes
and obviously probably chest feeding or
something like that than he is rail safety.
Speaker 1: Now, chest feeding, this is something
that Lauren Boebert started with being a judge.
It's just straight up homophobic. Pete
booted judge took paternity leave.
That's the story. And they talk about maybe he was
home, chest feeding. And, of course, this is what
they are saying because the judge is gay, that
this this is a homophobic attack on people. To
judge if this were good. I don't know. But I don't
know if I was going to say George Santos. But
Santos is gay. The point here is they're talking
about people to judge chest feeding because of the
stereotypes about gay men being feminine. So the
homophobia continues. But more importantly here,
Marjorie Taylor GREENE is saying, oh, there's
a Democrat who is secretary of transportation.
Let's blame him for what took place in Ohio rather
than all of the Ohio infrastructure and political
establishment, which is overwhelmingly run by
Republicans. No, no, no, no. It's the fault of
Bush, a judge in Washington, D.C. And.
Speaker 3: That's where we have real
danger in our country. Yeah, you see, But
a judge was never qualified for the job.
Speaker 1: And sort of like
she's not qualified for her job.
Speaker 3: We need to haul him in, in our
committees and start questioning him over
what's actually happening in his department,
because train derailment is happening every
single day. And now thousands of people,
birds, animals, they're all sick. And we
don't know the consequences of this
horrible accident in East Palestine.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: You know, she throws
in train derailments are happening every single
day. That's one of those statements. That's true
and is completely misleading when you look at what
that means. There is about a thousand incidents a
year that are called train derailment incidents.
So it is like three a day. Understand that the
overwhelming majority of these are minor incidents
with absolutely no injuries, never mind deaths,
often involving city rail transit like subways
and commuter rails and this sort of thing. Often
they're weather related. They are derailments of,
you know, a part of one car. And it's really not
representative of any kind of particularly major
problem. And of course, it happens whether the
secretary of transportation is a Democrat or
a Republican under Elaine Chao as secretary
of transportation. You also had about a thousand
derailments of different kinds of year. So it's
all dishonest, it's all nonsense. But they don't
care. They just want to find someone to blame.
One more clip here real quick. This is Jesse
Waters saying this is the the racist black EPA
administrator trying to hurt white people.
Speaker 2: So where's the EPA?
If they say my plastic straw
is destroying this country,
then they must be all over a cancer causing gas
bomb in the Ohio River Valley. Right? Or the
random toxic ash that's raining down in Illinois.
Speaker 1: By the way, it's funny how now
suddenly conservatives care about
pollution in the environment.
Speaker 2: Surely the EPA administrator, Michael
Reagan, no relation to Ron, is too zoned in on
electric school busses to care about poisoned
drinking water. He just announced a pledge to
support electric school busses nationwide.
You have cancer. Here's an electric bus.
Does this guy Reagan even know anything about the
environment? Oh, we looked in to him, and the only
reason he was nominated to run the EPA was because
he promised to fight off environmental racism.
Is this his idea of fighting
environmental racism, spilling
toxic chemicals on poor white people in Ohio?
Speaker 1: Why do you make everything about
race? They say to the left, Why? Why
do you see race in every issue? Well,
it seems like these right wingers are very
much seeing race in this issue unhinged.
Brain worms is what they're suffering from.
But people hear it and they fall for it.